(gentle music)
- Innovation is essential
because the society
that we're working with
and trying to protect
from the ills of public health problems
is a society that's changing very quickly,
and when a society changes quickly,
we need to innovate in response to that.
We were very interested
in the question of,
what is causing cancer?
It's a very widespread
concern people have,
but moreover, a given
patient often wants to know
what caused their cancer.
And in the past, what
people have been able to say
are things like, oh, well if you smoke
you are more likely to get cancer.
If you have this genetic preposition,
But that's not really an
answer to the question of,
why did I get cancer?
And on just recently we've been
able to answer that question
by doing tumor sequencing,
being able to see the actual effects
of what's causing the mutations
that led to that tumor
and then being able to quantify
how those mutations
contribute to the tumor
so that we can actually ask the question,
if someone has lung cancer,
what proportion of your
cancer was caused by smoking?
What proportion was by age?
What proportion was by viral infection?
These sorts of things are
things that in the past
we've never been able to tell someone.
And it's the kind of
innovation that hopefully
will be helpful in improving public health
by being able to tell people
why they're getting ill
and by expressing that
information to those who get ill,
and for having those people
pass that information on
to those they love, so that
they can better understand
what they can do to prevent
the same ills from affecting them.
In the past we've always had to do sort of
what one might call gumshoe epidemiology,
which is like investigating
all the possible causes
that might relate to the people's cancer
and sort of just figuring out
from no information whatsoever
by being in the area and exploring
what sort of carcinogens
they may have encountered,
why they're more likely to
have come up with a cancer.
But in this case, we could
actually take those individuals
who get cancer and look at the
tumor genome that they have
and better understand what sorts of causes
might be apparent just from
what kinds of mutations occur
in the tumor genome.
And from that, that
may give us a direction
and a faster route towards
understanding these hotspots
where individuals get cancer
at higher rates than at other places.
I think the Yale School of Public Health
has a very great appreciation
of the complexity
of the society we live in
and the fact that the
society that we live in
is changing very rapidly.
And so at the core of its
mission is the idea that
we need to develop the science
that underlies the policy decision making
and the science progress
that we need to make
in terms of innovating for public health.
(gentle music)